I made my first $100,000 when I was
23-years-old when I opened my first gym
location. In this video, I'm going to
cover everything I learned from that.
And so first, it's going to be how I
started it. Next, my first 100,000. And
then third, and most importantly for
you, the lessons and tactics that I
still use to this day that you can use
too to help you grow your business. And
it felt appropriate to film this video
in my current gym in the background
because this is where I kind of it all
started for me. So, let's talk about how
this even started. The reason this was
the riskiest move in my life was that
one, quitting my job was the hardest
thing ever. Two, it was during a time
where like the economy still wasn't like
roaring. It was like, kind of okay. And
I had saved up $50,000 from my job. Now,
I spent 10 to get into the the group for
the gym owners. I actually signed up for
a gym mastermind and I didn't have a
gym. So, I had like 40,000 left. And
then I spent $34,000 opening up the
location. So, I had $6,000 left. Mind
you, the rent was five.
And so, I had exactly the amount of
money like required to have like one
month. And so, I was like, "Oh my god,
what am I going to do?" And so, it was
by chance that I went to a different
seminar that taught about this thing
called Facebook ad. And so, I ended up
running an ad and here's the craziest
thing of all, I actually found this out
years later. $4,972
in cash collected in the first month.
And my rent was $4,972.
I only found this out years later when I
looked at my processing records. And I
was like, "I'm not I'm not a divine, you
know, dude, but wild."
Um and so, I basically had no money and
all my money was in the gym equipment
and I spent the thousand bucks basically
that I had on these ads. And so, when I
started this one, I was like, "Man, this
is this is hard." So, first big lesson
that I learned was when you're poor,
barter. All right? And so, I had
basically no money. And so, but I needed
stuff. So, I needed people who could
train. I needed people who could clean.
And so, I had people come in and be
like, "I can't afford to do this." And
I'd be like, "Hey, well, you want to
clean the gym?" And if you clean the
gym, I'll let you attend the classes.
Cuz the class the like someone else
attending a class for me wasn't really
any cost for me. And I mean my costs
were fixed. So, anything that I could
basically barter for $200 a month or
$300 a month of services, I would just I
did everything like that. I was like,
"Hey, can you fix my computer? One
personal training?" Like I did that like
I got my first printer and scanner from
a guy who had an IT company because he
felt bad for me because I was doing
everything on paper. And he said, "You
shouldn't do this." And I just did PT
lessons for him so that he would pay for
that.
And so like I just I barter like crazy.
I still barter this day because guys,
it's tax efficient. Neither party has to
pay taxes on anything, right? It's the
most efficient form of trade. So, if you
have the opportunity to do it, do it. On
top of that, I actually had a client who
was a food like a food prep person. And
so, they would end up bringing a
refrigerator and I could eat the food
that they would bring for free for
having access to my members. So, like
I'm saying literally everything. My
laundry, I had a different client who
did my laundry for me. Like everything
that would take any of my time or money,
I just traded for so that I could spend
all my time in the gym just trying to
make this thing work. So, if you're
like, "Okay, well how do I apply this to
me?" Look at every single line item that
you have on your like your expenses,
right? Like your credit card or whatever
your bank account. And anything that I
had, I just tried to find somebody who
did that thing. And I just was
opportunistic look looking. If somebody
came in and they're like, "Oh, I do" cuz
I would always be like, "Ah, what do you
do?" And they would tell me. I'd be
like, "Ooh, I actually need one of that.
Want to
want to do this?" And this happened a
lot.
And I would just keep asking for less
and less service until it was the amount
of money that was the equivalent of a
membership. And then I was like, "Sick,
let's do that." My first ads, I got a
videographer who came in cuz it was
California, right? And this guy comes in
and he's he's a small-time videographer.
And he was like, "I can't afford this."
And I was like, "Well, I can't afford
you. So" and so he recorded my first
some of my first ads for the gym, which
actually ended up crushing. And so, like
just you got like bartering is one, but
I'll put it a second here, which is like
be creative. And I think in order to do
this, too, is that you just can't have
an ego. Now, I was lucky that I was, you
know, 23 and, you know, poor. And And so
like I had no shame for asking. I was
like, "Please. Like, help. I like
I need it." And so I think that a lot of
I'll just I'll be honest with you guys.
I see a lot of y'alls Instagrams. You
know who you are. And a lot of you guys
are posturing and pretending like you
have something that you don't. And it
actually I think it actually does a lot
of disservice to you. Because if you're
like, "Hey, I need help. Hey, I'm trying
to build this thing." People will reach
out and help. People will be way more
willing. If you pretend like you're, you
know, you've got it all figured out, no
one's going to try and help you. And I
think at that time is like when like
when you're earlier on is when you want
all the lessons, you want all the favors
you can get. And the way that I could
get extra calories in is that I would
actually, uh, with the food prep stuff,
I would sell clients on food prep and
sometimes some of them wouldn't pick up
all their meals. It happens. And so I
would wait for the food to expire and
then as soon as it expired, uh, we
weren't allowed to distribute it
anymore. And so I would just take it.
And I would eat all of the
expired It's fine. I called the people
and if they didn't respond, then I would
then I would take it. And that's that's
how I fed myself. Um, and for those of
you who have a moral quandary with me,
suck it. Next thing. While I was trying
to eat, I was growing, all right? Now,
number two is that when you're early,
you need tactics, all right? Which is
why I make a lot of the videos that I
do. Actually, to be fair, you need
tactics at all levels, but especially
when you're starting out because you're
not really thinking in terms of
strategy. You're just like, "Shoot, what
fire should I have in front of me? I got
to pay bills. Like, let's get this
done." And so I joined this mastermind
of a guy who had a really successful
gym, Sam Back to You. And he had a group
of, I think, probably like 30 or 40 gym
owners who had paid him to like kind of
learn some of the stuff that he had. So
I showed up to this first mastermind and
I'm 20 22 years old at the time and I
didn't own a gym. But the most valuable
thing that I got is so many mistakes
that I didn't have to make that all of
these guys had made when they started
their gyms. And so I just went around
the room and I was like, "Hey, so what
kind of location were you looking for?"
And they were like, "Oh, definitely
don't do it in these markets. You
definitely want to have this kind of
square footage. Try to get a layout that
only has a this much office and this
much, uh, warehouse." I was like, and
they're like, "Oh, yeah, parking. Make
sure you have" And so all of these
things." And I was like, "Okay, well,
I'm going to buy this equipment."
They're like, "Oh, no, don't buy that
equipment. That stuff breaks really
fast. Buy from this brand. And then I've
got a guy, I'll hook you up with him."
And like, within the first conversation,
I was like, "Oh my god, I saved the
entire cost of what I paid in the first
day." And basically, that was such a
reinforcing experience for me that
whenever I enter anything, I always just
pay, if I can, to just get access to
people who are already doing it, and
they can just tell me all the mistakes
that I can avoid up front. And this is
why I invested in school. Like, I think
communities are the future. Anyways.
They also told me, so on top of that,
what I would do is on my weekends when I
had time, which was basically never, but
when I did have time, I would make
weekend trips to the other gym owners in
the community. And so then I would just
basically shadow them and pester them
like a leech. And I would just go there
and I would just ask as many questions
as I could. I'd be like, "Why do you do
that? And then when they sign up, what
do you do? Where do you put the
contract?" I asked a hundred questions.
But the thing is is all these guys were
older than me, and they like kind of
felt bad. They were like, "Yeah, this is
what I do. This is what I do. This is
what I do." And I just took every note I
possibly could. And so I think the meta
lesson for me was that the thing that
has carried me into this day has just
been the intention to keep learning. And
I think that life, like for me, the
meaning of life is learning, is to
change behavior based on the conditions.
And so I hope that I live the end of my
life differently than I do now.
Hopefully, I'll have learned. And so, um
I went to all the gyms, I asked tons of
questions, and all of those little
things that I learned, I would try. And
not all of them worked, obviously, but
some of them did. And so I just tossed
out the stuff that didn't work. I wasn't
like, "Screw that guy for trying to help
me for free uh cuz he gave me a tactic
that didn't work." It's like, "Well, he
gave me another one that did, so works
for me." And so I'll give you this
little thing, which is that when you're
starting out, it's actually one of the
only times that people are willing to
help you. And so take advantage of that.
Like this is a strategic advantage that
you have when you're starting out is
that people are willing to help,
especially other entrepreneurs. It's
like fairly common. Like most
entrepreneurs are willing to help people
one or two steps behind them. Now, this
was a big mistake that I made, which is
number three, which after I learned
this, I I forever changed how I do every
business, all right? Which is that
pre-sells. So, I thought that the way
that I should make money, cuz I was
like, "I don't have any money. I need to
start this gym as fast as possible in
order to make money. Completely wrong.
What you guys are doing is marketing and
selling as fast as possible and then
delay delivering as long as possible.
Because every location I opened after my
first after having learned this lesson,
I was like, "Oh, we're going to pre-sell
for 3 months. And we're just going to
keep marketing, keep selling, keep
collecting cash, keep getting members,
keep getting members, keep getting
memberships, right?" And then only like
basically as long as possible. Because
that's when all your costs start. So
it's like, just market and sell, get
people to pre-pay for, you know, 3
months, 6 months, a year, right? Get
people into into trial memberships that
kick in later. Like whatever you need to
do in the beginning to just start kind
of with a bang. And so if you're
brick-and-mortar more than anything,
obviously every kind of business would
benefit from a grand opening strategy.
But if you're brick-and-mortar, grand
opening strategy is is one of the core
ways you scale. Like you cannot scale
without having a killer grand opening
strategy. Look at every every
brick-and-mortar, retail, food, gyms,
like, you know, massage parlors, it
doesn't matter. They have a a crazy
grand opening strategy. Otherwise, like
it takes so it takes way too long to get
your money back, right? You have to be
able to get to be profitable as humanly
possible. And so what I did with
pre-sells as I got more sophisticated is
that if I instead of being like, "Oh, I
think I want to open up a location in,
you know, La Habra." What I would do is
I would run ads. So I'd spend like $500
or $1,000 in five or 10 markets. And I
would see where I got the lowest lead
costs. And so as soon as I saw that, I
was like, "Oh, well, some people are
like, 'Oh man, it's such like dude, that
guy's market is so easy compared to
mine.'" And I'm going to be real with
you. Some markets are easier than
others. Like there are better and worse
markets, absolutely, for any type of
service. But guess how you can pay down
that risk. So instead of signing a
lease, doing a build-out, and then
beginning to market to figure out
whether it's a good a good location or
not, do it first. Worst-case scenario,
you spend the $5,000 or $10,000 in ads
across 10 locations, and you pick a
perfect spot, a one out of 10 spot,
rather than a
who knows what location. So instead of
rolling the dice, pay $10,000 for
pre-sale insurance of checking. And it's
like, okay, if you're wondering what
Well, what do you do when when when when
people opt in and then you don't have a
location? Do what 99% of business owners
do anyways. Ignore the leads.
Right? That's what everyone else does.
So, like don't worry about it. Like,
you'll be okay. They'll just keep living
their lives and you paid at Google and
Google got their benefit and everybody's
happy, right? But you get to avoid
signing a 5-year lease and a for 500
grand or whatever it is that you're
signing
for a bad spot. And I want to be really
clear.
Don't
I can't believe I have to say this.
Don't sell
that you're not going to deliver. If for
whatever reason you think you're not
going to open up a location, for for
sake, don't
take money and not deliver. Like, a
really great way to just have people
hate you. So, don't do that. And get in
trouble. Don't do that.
So, the next big lesson I have
was variation in ads. All right? So, I'm
going to explain this. This skill ended
up benefiting me for the rest of my
life. And so, when most marketers
advertise on a national level, they get
really lazy because they're used to
running an ad and having an ad work for
a month, two months, three months.
Sometimes like YouTube ads have to run
for six months. I wasn't that guy at
all. I had to make new ads like every
week because my local market is so
small, right? And so, in the In 100
Million Dollar Offers, the last chapter,
I talk about the magic headline formula.
And so, basically what I what I figured
out was that I can't I don't want to
change my service, right? I don't want
to I don't want to start like offering
back massages or something at my gym.
Like, that I don't You don't want to
change your core thing. But what I want
to do is change the wrapping paper. So,
it's the same present. I just present it
differently. And so, that's how I got
you know, that's how I figured out, "Oh,
okay.
Lean by Halloween. Slim for Santa. Big
Booty Bootcamp. 42-Day Detox. 42-Day
Fix. 42-Day Transformation. 6-Week
Transformation. 6-Week Challenge." Like,
I learned how to permutate my
promotional headlines because I had to.
And then later on, once I went to a
national level, I was willing and able
to make so much more variation in my
ads, in my copy, in my lead magnets than
my competitors because all of them were
spoiled in this world where they only
have to make a couple ads a month. I was
like, I'm used to making 20 or 30 a
week. And so this is where I actually
learned both the volume of creative and
the variation. And it's really just
slight variation in the naming
conventions
of the promotions that I'm running. All
right, and so it might you want to make
it look like a different offer, but
you're still I mean, what's it going to
be? It's still going to be you're going
to work out a couple times a week,
you're going to eat differently, you're
going to have a trainer. Like, the core
deliverable is the same, it's not going
to change. But you just change the way
it looks, the change the way it feels,
and that's what keeps it new in a
market. Yeah, and what's changed between
when I learned this lesson and today is
that
the creative itself is part of the
targeting now. And so who you have in
the ads, like like attracts like. And so
if you want more girls, have more girls
in the ads. You want more guys, have
more guys in the ads. You want big
jacked guys, have more big jacked guys.
If like And so this is something that is
more new now than then cuz then the
targeting was much more basic.
But big picture, if you're local, you
don't need to worry too much about this
cuz you're just going to drop a pin and
say everybody in this local area. But as
you go national, that's where it becomes
a little bit more important. Hey, and
real quick, I spent 200 hours this year
just making this one project for you,
which is the $100 million scaling road
map. And I broke up the stages of
business into 10 stages, and you can
identify where you're at by simply just
putting in your business information.
You go to acquisition.com/roadmap,
and it'll spit out this custom report
that tells you what the constraints are
at that current level and what you need
to do
to graduate and get to the next level.
This is our gift to you, absolutely
free. On the thank you page, you can
book a call with our team, and we'd love
to help you figure that out and ideally
get past it. So this is how I was
generating leads. But then what was the
actual offer that really like made or
broke the business? Right? And so this
is where I learned the six-week
challenge offer. And the six-week
challenge offer is a win your money back
offer.
And there was also an unconditional
money back guarantee that I paired with
this. So, it just made it an absolute
hurricane of an offer. And if you're
curious about guarantees,
I have a chapter on guarantees in
general, the guarantee formula, which is
just if you don't achieve X by Y time, I
will Z, which is what's the
consideration. So, you have some sort of
thing you're promising, there's some
sort of timeline you're promising it on,
some terms, and then you have what
you'll give in consideration. And so,
one of the big mistakes people make when
they're doing any kind of guarantee
offer is that they say, "I guarantee
this." Yeah, but you have to say the or
what, right? The or else. And it's the
or what that gives the guarantee power.
Just the word guarantee is not going to
do nearly as much as the stakes you're
putting on the line. Now, inside of the
book, I actually have 11 of my favorite
guarantees that have I have used and
work. And so, you can you can check
those out. But the two guarantees that I
use most frequently were a service-based
guarantee and an unconditional
guarantee. All right, so let me explain
what those are. So, a service-based
guarantee is, "Hey, I'm going to help
you achieve X by Y, but if you don't,
I'll continue to work with you until you
do." Now, this matters more importantly
when there's actual cost associated with
delivery. If you're like, "I will, you
know, you're you're a digital person
that's like, yeah, you get access to
this course for 6 weeks, and then if you
don't hit the goal, you keep getting
access for another 6 weeks." It's like
access is not that valuable of like a I
didn't hit it. But we were actually
training people. And so, for me, that
was like real stakes on the line, and it
was very compelling. The second
guarantee that I offered was an
unconditional guarantee, which is that
during the 6 weeks, if at any point you
feel like you haven't gotten $500 of
value from us, independent of your
results, I'll give you the money back. I
says, "That means that 5 weeks, 6 days,
and 23 hours from now, if you don't
think that we gave you the value, I'll
give you the money back." And I'm
telling you, like that closed so many
sales for me, and because we really
obsessed on delivery, my team knowing
that that guarantee exist forced them to
just level up and be like, we just have
to bring it every day. And I want to
tell you the actual number, which is
over the years of doing it, I had two
people who asked me for their money back
on the unconditional. Now, there were
people who obviously hit the goal of
losing 20 lb in the 6 weeks and they won
it, which is fine, and that's kind of
that was the that was the deal, right?
Which if you aren't familiar with the
offer, it was
uh lose 20 lb in 6 weeks. Obviously,
this is for people who are over certain
BMI. If they were below the BMI, we'd
just say 10% of your body weight. So, if
it was like a 140-lb
uh you know, person and they're like a
little overweight, they lose 14 lb in 6
weeks. That's like 2 lb a week or two
two and change. And mind you, like I
knew that people people were like, "Oh,
in the comments, like, oh my god, that's
unhealthy." People gamed it. I know
that. So, when they came to weigh-in
day, they were they had 6 lb of water
and you know, bricks in their pockets.
Like, I I knew people were gaming it,
right? It's like, to be clear. And at
the end, they're like dehydrated like a
raisin. You know, they're naked on there
just like, you know, covering covering
themselves to like get underweight. So,
like the weight like I knew there was a
5 or 6 lb give on both sides that were
happening, right? But we had almost 80%
of people were hitting the goal at the
time. And so, it was very compelling.
And the the reality is that most people
who work out for 6 weeks straight want
to keep working out. And so, that's why
the offer worked. It got people really
motivated in the short term, but then it
was like, "Hey, listen, Cindy, you've
lost 14 lb. That's amazing. You told me
your goal is 50, though. Yeah, okay.
Well, it's going to take longer than
that, right? Yeah, I know it's going to
take longer than Cool, then let's just
get you going for a year and actually
get you there for good, right? So, it's
very easy transition, even though people
came in for a defined in program in the
front end. Now, the beauty of this
particular offer was that compared to
the rest of the industry, everyone else
is giving free trials, free months, or
low-barrier offers like $21 for 21 days,
things like that. And so, when they were
trying to market against me, I was
making $500 in the in the first
transaction, and then 48 hours later, I
was selling another $200, $300 of
supplements. I had so much more cash up
front, I could wildly outspend them. For
them, they have $21, okay, basically
nothing, and then they have to wait
three weeks to convert into a normal
membership price of 99, 199 a month, and
it would take them three months to just
get what I got in the first transaction.
And because of that, I was able to
massively outspend them. And so by doing
that play, I was able to dominate
markets. And the beauty of the
guarantee, the way I had it structured,
was one, obviously there was a goal, and
if they won their money back by hitting
the goal, they had it. straight up, they
have they have the money back. Um
sometimes, some like later on, we
started doing it as credit, saying,
"Hey, this is credit, so we'll credit it
back to what any other services." You
just have to disclaim in the
advertising, all that stuff, obey the
laws of your area, whatever. Now, beyond
that, what it enabled me to do is do
something like is one of my favorite
closes ever, which is the best case
worst case close. And so I'll be like,
"Hey Cindy, let's just zoom out for a
second. Best case scenario, you change
your life forever, you finally get in
shape, you find a community of people,
and you actually stick with this for
life. That's best case. Worst case
scenario, you work out for six weeks
basically for free, you tell me I suck,
and I give you your money back. You have
nothing to lose, except the only thing
that is more guaranteed than that is
that if you leave, you're definitely not
going to get to where you want to go. So
what do you want to do?"
Like, it was a risk-free move, and that
closed a lot.
So all of this stuff is what helped me
get to $100,000, multiple $100,000 in
revenue the first year. Now, I also had
a decent amount of profit that was left
over. But the thing is is that I didn't
take that money out of the business. I
left the cash in the business, and then
when I opened my second location, it's
like that cash from my first location,
and basically spent it all on the
second, right? It cost me 250 grand for
the second location, which is a big
mistake. I way overspent because my ego
was tied to it. But the thing is is that
it only it took years before I actually
ended up act- taking money out of the
business and putting it in my personal
bank account. The richest I've ever
felt, which I talk about in the last
story of this book,
um was when I put $100,000 into my bank
account um from the launch business. And
so I kept doubling down on new location,
new location, new location, new
location. And so I felt like I was
living on like a razor's edge because
like I basically had I was really asset
rich and cash poor. I just had all these
locations, all this equipment, all this
payroll due every month. And so there
was cash in all the bank accounts of the
businesses, but like nothing in mine.
And I think if I could do it over again,
I would have said, "Dude, like what's
the rush? Like why are you rushing?
Like take money out. Like get yourself
set up so you can breathe." And so I
think that I was running on such high
like stress at all times that it im- it
dramatically impacted my ability to make
good decisions because like there is no
finish line. There's no like there's no
award I get. Like it like it's not like
there's a network effect in gyms. Like
you just have to keep executing really
well for a very long period of time and
then eventually you can build something
that has hundreds and thousands of
locations. But like you still have to
run a really good business. And I just
had this artificial sense of rush
because I was trying to prove myself to
everyone in my head that didn't even
care about me anyways. Now, the
interesting thing with this whole
challenge thing is that it took me a
while to get good at it. So the first
challenge I ever ran only 15% of people
lost the weight. And what's interesting
is that between then and you know, a
year later, multiple years later, like
we were almost 80%. But like
fundamentally we still had more or less
the same workouts and the meal plans
that I provided in terms of the calorie
restrictions that are were basically the
same thing. And so it's like what was
the difference? And so the difference
was I actually learned how to operate a
business. Number two is I really leaned
on to accountability.
Which is like make reminding people to
show up to the gym, reminding people to
follow their meal plans, telling people
they have to weigh on a regular basis,
making sure they're documenting that
publicly. Like I started doing all these
little things, right? There was no one
thing that made it just like every time
we just got better and better and
better. So even though the stakes were
there with the money, that actually was
enough to motivate some people, but the
reality is that like I should have just
made it easier. So I like took the meal
plans and I made them color coded and I
made them uh they didn't have to weigh
anything, they didn't have to count
calories. Like I learned a lot of things
that made it more accessible to people
who were just getting started cuz I was
starting as a I was starting with
beginners, but I was an advanced you
know, fitness person at the time. I had
multiple state records. Like I was like
I was hardcore in it, but like the
people I was serving were not me. And it
took me a minute to learn that.
And I'll tell you how I figured this
out. So, I remember freaking out uh near
the end of the very first challenge I
ever ran. I called my dad up. He's a
physician. And I was like, "I think I'm
crashing people's hormones and
metabolism. And maybe I'm I'm
restricting their calories too much.
That's why they're they're not losing
weight." And any experienced doctor will
tell you he's like, "Oh, they're just
not adhering." And I was like, "No, it's
obviously not that. It's obviously like
some sort of scientific thing." And
obviously he was right. It was just no
one was no one was following it, right?
And so, um one of the things that I
learned and this is good for anybody who
has clients who have to do anything to
get a result. So, it doesn't matter what
you sell, but if you have a service
where a customer has to take action in
order to see an outcome, what I learned
was asking specific questions. So, when
I would ask people, "Hey, did you follow
everything?" In the beginning, they're
all like, "Oh, yeah. Followed everything
to the T. 100%." And then I could
literally follow that up with, "Okay, so
how many days out of seven did you eat
all three meals exactly to plan with
nothing else?" And they'd be like, "Oh,
I mean at least three days a week." And
I'd be like, "You just said that you
followed it 100%." And then the next
question was, "How many days out of
seven did you eat all three and nothing
else?" They were like, "Oh, yeah. Only
three." Right? And so, I got more
specific about it like, "How many times
did you have three and two shakes or
whatever?" And they would be like, "Oh,
that's what I had." Now, if anybody
who's like listening to this is like,
"Oh, fitness stuff." Point being is that
ask specific questions and you'll get
much more specific answers. Now, the
sixth thing that kind of got me to that
$100,000 plus was sell the vacation, not
the plane flight. So, what I want to
give you a visual on this cuz I think
it's really important. Like this when I
understood how this worked for sales, it
really changed
I mean, how much money I made. So, what
happens is let's say somebody's here,
right? They're sad cuz they're like,
"Ah, I'm sad and my eyes are really
weird. I look like a cyclops." Uh
right, I'd be sad if I look like that,
right? And they want to get over here,
right? They want to be happy version of
them who's got eyes that are evenly
spaced and has a smiley face. Now,
there's going to be some process of
getting them here, right? Now, what
happens is most sales people will talk
about all of the steps of getting here,
right? That's what they're going to talk
about. And the thing is is that that's
like telling somebody, "Hey, I want you
to go on this vacation." And so, what's
going to be required is you're going to
have to wake up at the crack of dawn,
you're going to have to pack your stuff
the night before, you're going to have
to be stressed out and to wait in line
and to pull your idea, they're going to
weigh it, you might have to pay an extra
bill, right? And then once you get uh to
the plane, they're going to make you sit
for another hour, and then you're going
to get called up like cattle and put
into the and put into the the
compartment of the plane, and you're
going to have somebody sneezing and
coughing next to you. Of course, there's
going to be a baby on the plane. They're
going to be crying the whole time. The
food's going to be terrible, and you
might get jet lag, there's going to be a
delay for sure, and by the way, did I
mention the layover? Yeah, you're going
to have to do it all again another time
in order to get your final location.
Now, once you get there, you're going to
actually not going to be there, you're
going to have to get in the You get the
point here, right? Painful. That's what
most people's sales sound like.
But instead, if I just said, "Hey,
you're here.
You want to be in Maui.
Let me tell you about Maui, and let me
tell you how it's not like Baltimore."
So, Baltimore, it's like it's it's it's
raining here, right? Ah, that's rain.
That's like a Looks like an octopus or a
jellyfish. Anyways, that's rain, all
right? So, it's raining here,
right? Look, rain. You've got your
little umbrella, very sad, right? It's
terrible here. What we want to talk
about is the pain of their current
situation.
Pain increases their their desire to
change. So, think about it this way. You
want to sell at the point of greatest
deprivation. So, that's why like when
someone's in pain is when they want to
go to a doctor, right? You want to solve
that. And so, we want to remind them of
the pain. So, you want to talk about
them where they're currently at, all the
problems that exist. Then, we say,
"Cool. Well, let me tell you about Maui.
Maui's got beautiful clear water. It's
got white white sand, very fine. It's
almost like powder when you're stepping
into it. You're going to have poolside
service and oceanside service, depending
on what you want. And you're going to
have a cabana boy who's got little
drinks with the little umbrellas in it,
and you're going to be sipping there,
having the time of your life, creating
memories that you will have for until
you die. And the thing is is that this
vacation isn't just going to pay
dividends when you're there. You're
going to enjoy it. But, you're going to
enjoy it two other times. Every day
leading up to it, you're going to be
looking forward to it. It's going to
make every day better. And then
afterwards, you're going to be able to
look back at those pictures and
re-experience it. And so, it's not even
about the vacation. It's about something
that you're going to be able to use and
think about for the rest of your life,
right? Notice what I didn't talk about.
The plane flight, the TSA, the guy the
baby, you know, smoking cigarettes next
to you. I don't know what this baby is
doing, but he's doing something crazy.
And so, the point is is that you want to
focus on the pain of their current and
then what the experience of the result
will be like. And then them signing up
is the process of getting there.
Now, this part's key.
Number seven
was the role of bonuses and discounts,
okay? Now, in the beginning, and I think
I learned this really early on, and so
I've never been a discounter when it
comes to my core product. Now, very
different than saying like I'm going to
peel a pre-sofa. It's going to be a lead
magnet. That's a different situation.
But, if someone wants me to discount my
core service, the answer is always no,
because we don't negotiate with price
terrorists. So,
what do you do instead? So, I'll give
you two different things that have
worked really well for me. So, number
one is that if somebody asks for a
discount, what I would prefer to do is
just add a bonus. If somebody asks for a
discount, the first answer I usually
says, "Well, I could do it for more."
Right? And a lot of times that gets
people to buy. Now, if they still don't
want to buy, they say, "Okay, how about
this?" Because maybe they're like, "I
literally can't." I'm like, "Okay, can
you refer me three friends? If you refer
me friends, I'll give you that discount.
Which is different because it changes
the terms. So if someone else finds out,
"Hey, you gave Suzy sign up for $400 and
you made me sign up for $500." I'm like,
"Oh dude, bring three friends. I'll give
you the $100 bucks right now." And
they're like, "Oh, she didn't say that."
I'm like, "Yeah, I changed the terms,
right?" And so you can use discounts as
bartering tools to have them advertise
for you. So like I'll give you 100 bucks
off if you also make reviews on all
these platforms or do other things. So
basically any kind of discount I'll have
my terms will change to all the
advertising they will allow me to do,
which is worth more to me than whatever
the discount is. Now, if somebody
presents with a specific obstacle, I'll
give you the actual story. So the first
time I realized this, there was this
lady, business professional, had the
money. She was like, "The money's not a
problem." I was like, "Okay." She said,
"The issue is I travel a lot for work."
And she's like, "So how am I going to be
able to stick with the plan when I'm not
here?" And she was like, "Do you have a
travel meal plan?" And I was like,
"Well, I don't." And she was like,
"Well, that's kind of a kind of a deal
break for me." And I was like, "Okay,
what if I made you a travel meal plan so
that every time you travel you know how
to order at the restaurant
uh so you can eat out and actually like,
you know, keep with this when you're
gone." And she was like, "Oh, if you can
do that for me, I'm in."
And so I made that thing for that one
lady, and then for every other person
after that when they'd come in and say,
"Hey, uh what happens if I travel or I
have to go somewhere for work or I have
this vacation in the middle, what do I
do?" I'd be like, "Oh, I'll give you the
travel plan." And then boom, the
obstacle is done. And so what happened
is I started collecting kind of all of
these obstacles that people would
present with for the reasons that they
wouldn't buy, and then I ended up making
things. So I made a budget guide meal
plan. So it's like, "I can afford the
thing, but I can't afford the food." I'm
like, "Oh, what are you spending on food
right now? Cool, this budget groceries
is cost less than 40 bucks a week and
you'll be able to to stick to the
calories and lose the weight." And
they're like, "Oh, that's amazing. I
might even save money on this plan." And
they're like, "What if I'm on the go?"
I'm like, "Oh, I've got the shakes
guide." "Oh, what if I like what if I
don't know what to eat for breakfast,
lunch, and dinner?" "Okay, well not only
will you follow the plan, I'll actually
give you specific breakfast, lunches,
and dinners that you can make with zero
prep." "Oh, what about working out when
I'm away?" "Oh, that's why I have my
while you're away workout guide."
"Right? What about if I can't make it in
the gym because of time constraints, can
I work out at home? Yep, I have my at
home workout guide. And so, basically
every single thing that people would
present with, I would take the one time
effort of making a beautiful solution
for them. And they're like, "Wow, you
went above and beyond." But then I took
that templated solution and I stuck it
in my stack so that when somebody would
talk to me and they'd bring up an
obstacle, I'd be like, "Oh, don't worry.
Something like this, would that help?"
And they're like, "Oh my god, that'd be
amazing." And so, I wouldn't in a
one-on-one selling situation, different
than group sales, I would have my big
stack of bonuses in my back pocket so
that if they presented with it, I would
just match their objection with the
bonus that would overcome it. So, this
was a this was a pretty terrible thing
in terms of lessons, which was uh
overspending. So, what made my first
location kind of like so successful was
that I was there and I we know went
above and beyond for customers and I
tried to, you know, make everyone happy.
And people could tell that I wasn't like
rolling in money, you know, like I you
know, I had a I had these sandbags that
like there's nice sandbags you can buy
they're like fitness sandbags. I went to
Home Depot and just bought sandbags. And
then just taped them with duct tape and
people just like would carry these like
babies around of of of sand, right? And
um so, when my second location happened,
I saved all this money up and I put
$250,000 in the second location. So,
like I spent or this eight times or
whatever it was more on my second
location than my first location. And
here's the crazy part. It made the same
amount of money as my first location.
And so, like it was way worse returns on
capital than my first one. And the thing
is is that I didn't actually understand
what made my product good. What made
people actually like my stuff. And so,
people weren't coming to the gym for
fancy top-tier equipment. They weren't
coming for granite countertops and a
glass wall, which is what I did. My
glass wall at my second location was
almost the same price as my entire first
location. What they were coming for was
the accountability and the quality of
the training, quality of the experience,
the people they liked. And so, that's
when it I mean, it took me
$250,000 to learn this lesson,
um which is that I had to understand
like what's the job to be done? What's
the job that I'm actually accomplishing
for the customer, right? Or for like
what does my product or service deliver?
And so for us it was community and
accountability. Like people are very
lonely, people want to feel like they
belong, and obviously they want to do
things that are good for themselves. But
what I realized over time is that the
people who stuck with it, a lot of them
didn't like dramatically change after
they'd done their weight loss
challenges, but they kept coming back
again and again. And they just liked it
cuz they wanted to look good, feel good.
They just wanted to just like feel good,
see their friends, listen to some music,
you know, get a little sweat on, and
then they'd go have their margaritas on
Tuesdays or whatever. And I used to get
really upset about that, but I was like
but it was cuz I didn't understand what
we were actually doing. What we're
really doing was providing a place for
people to like get away from home. And
get away from work. It was like that
third spot. I think Starbucks talks
about that. Like what's that third
location? Like for us, the gym was that.
I think the only way you can really
discover this is by actually talking to
your customers. And just asking them.
And saying like what what need does this
fill for free fulfill for you? Like what
problem does this solve? Like where does
this fit in your life? And I think
listening qualitatively to the feedback,
you'd find out like in the the key when
you're asking these things is you don't
want to lead them on. You don't want to
say like, "Are we the third location for
between your house and your you know
like your job? Are we that thing that
fills your community hole up?" It's
like, "No, that's not what you're
asking." You're just saying you want to
keep it super open cuz you want them to
tell you. And what that has helped me
with is where I allocate my time in
terms of reinvestment in the service or
product to make it better. Cuz it's not
better in my eyes, it has to be better
in their eyes. Cuz I spent way too long
obsessing over like the periodization of
the training and like and I'd completely
disregarded the music, but like the
music mattered more to people than like
the training.
Like in terms of the actual workouts,
not the quality of the trainer,
different. But like how many reps and
sets they were doing, how much volume
they were doing, like they didn't care
at all. I mean shoot, half the time
they'd skip a workout or two. So like
the periodization was irrelevant, right?
But I was so obsessed with that cuz I
was into it. Yeah, and I think I think
the vast majority of business owners
spend a huge amount of time solving
problems that aren't problems.
And so it's like you completely and
excellently solve something that only
you think is a problem.
And so that's where like this tremendous
waste of resources happens.
Now, let me tell you the next big lesson
I had, which was
proof.
So, what I did was
and I recommend this to every
brick-and-mortar business owner,
is if you have a sales area or a sales
room, these are examples that I have of
before and after pictures. Obviously,
you need permissions and all that stuff
from people. Make sure you're following
the law, but just showing overwhelming
social proof. And so right now, if you
have Yelp or you have Google or
whatever, there's going to be all these
five stars you've gotten. People have
left you reviews. Well, what a waste for
them to only live there. So, screenshot
them. Go to the dollar store.
Buy $1 frames and then frame them all.
And so when somebody's in your sales
office, if all they see around you is
before and after pictures of people
saying you're great, it's hard for them
to be like, well, is this place legit?
You're like, I mean, yeah. And then I
ask And this is the question I This is
the question I'd ask.
Well, how much proof would you need to
see in order to believe? And then the
follow-up question is, and if they like
didn't, you know, be like, and is that
reasonable? Because you tell me when is
it that one like 1 2 3 4 Just tell me
when. 5 6 7 8 Just tell me when it's
good. 9 10 They'll be like, you know,
stop. I get it. I'm like, right. So
like, at some point it probably isn't
about that. It's about something you're
afraid of. So what are you afraid of?
Right now, I'm back in the sale and I'm
actually dealing with the real thing,
the reason behind the reason, not the
easy one that's a smoke screen that
they're just putting out to not buy.
Mostly because let's be real. Someone
for at least for a gym, they're scared.
They're afraid they're going to get made
fun of. They're afraid they're going to
slip. They're afraid to look stupid,
right? That's the big fears that people
I didn't even realize this when I It
took me a long time to realize that like
these are actual fears for people. And
it was weird for me cuz I love the gym.
So I'm like, everyone should love the
gym. But it wasn't like that at all.
Yeah, and so I I made a whole video
about this, like required viewing for
business owners. You can go check it
out. And inside the video, I basically
talk about a flywheel that every
business has to have. And I realize I
learned it with this business, which is
that you're going to get customers in
the door, step one. You're going to get
those customers results, step two. And
then step three, you need to use those
results to get you more customers. And
so, that's the flywheel that every
business needs to build. And so, you
have moments in your customer experience
or where your product experience where
customers are going to get these wow
moments, right? Or ideally, right? And
you want to be there at those moments to
capture their reactions so that you can
feed that into your marketing machine.
Right? And so, there's There's the
milestones along the way and then
obviously the end goal. And so, for us,
obviously with challenges, we was easy
to be like, "Weigh in, weigh out, big
moment, awesome picture, video. Was this
great?" Yeah. "Leave us a review,
fantastic." And so, trying to engineer
that into your customer experience,
primo way to get more customers and
enhance your sales. I'm going to finish
that by saying,
proof system and displaying. So, it's
both both collection and displaying of
the proof. Now, the next one uh was
partners. Now,
man, it's taken me a very long time
to learn learn my lessons with partners,
all right? So, I have this really nice
acronym uh for partners I'm going to
share with you. So, if you want a
partner to join your team, they should
they should accomplish one of the team
acronyms, which is mean either they have
time that you don't have, they've got
expertise that you don't have,
they've got assets that you don't have,
or they've got money
that you don't have.
So, assets would be like they've got a
brand, they've got a following, they've
got an audience, they might have a
machine. I mean, whatever. They have
something, they have a distribution base
of of customers, they have a network of
affiliates, whatever. They have
something that you don't have.
They have expertise, they have a skill
that you don't have. You can't do this
without having the skill. They can work
and you're predisposed. Or they've got
money and you need it. Right? But
fundamentally, every single partnership
should have one or more of these things
that they're bringing to the table
that's complementary.
If the worst business partnerships in
the the is when two people have the same
expertise get into business together cuz
they're friends. It's like the recipe
for bad partnership. Two lessons on
partnerships beyond the team framework.
Number one is that if one of you is the
working partner and somebody else is the
outside partner who's maybe funding it,
you need to figure out if you're going
to have some sort of salary to live on.
This was a mistake that I made and I
basically lived without taking a salary
from the business cuz I brought in
partners and they weren't taking a
salary, but I was the one working in the
business and they weren't. And so I
basically lived without taking an income
for 2 years. And so the reason that I'm
so sensitive to cheapness and personal
finance is because like what I made in
the first five or six months of me being
in business is what I lived on for the
next 2 years. And so I lived on like
$30,000 a year or less. And that's why I
was so sensitive to it. The idea is make
sure that you have some reasonable
compensation if you're going to be the
manager of the business because
long-term you need somebody else who's
going to be the manager in your stead.
So that's a cost that the business is
going to have to incur regardless and
you're doing the job in addition to
being the owner. So that's like there's
you want to make sure that that's clear.
Are you doing a job in the business
different than the other? That's only
going to be in the situations when
somebody's funding your thing. All
right, point one. The second point is
that the equity that you give away in
the beginning is the most expensive. And
so to the degree that you possibly can,
hold out on giving equity away early.
Now, if you have to bring people in and
you absolutely need them, then sure.
That's that's part of the game. But I
would it's just like it's so often that
someone's like, "Cool, here's the pie.
There's two of us. Boom, here's half,
right?" You don't always have to split
things evenly between the number of
people. There's different value of
skills. There's different value of
experience. There's knowledge that. So
like you can bring two people in and
each of them can have 5% and then you
have 90. Like the the the slices of the
pie don't necessarily need to be the
same. And a big variable they have there
is are they taking a paycheck or not,
right? And so it's a lot of this has to
come down to one big word, risk. Who's
taking on the most risk? And so
typically that is how the pie is sliced.
So number 11 was owners. You're like,
how is that different than partners? Let
me explain.
So every brick and mortar now I've I've
a lot of experience with this now, but
every brick and mortar business that I
know that's been scaled privately, not
franchised, which actually still follows
the same law, but that scales privately
with one or you know, a couple owners
that own everything is that they figure
out that every brick and mortar location
typically needs to do a profit share.
They need to have somebody
that they have they have they have a
what feels like a stake in the location.
So if you look at like Chick-fil-A for
example, they have their location
operators. And those operators have a
percentage of the profit from each
location. Now, they're not the majority
owners, they don't have controlling, but
they can run the day-to-day operations.
And so basically every brick and mortar
business that I have seen scale has this
thing. Now, some people ask the
question, well, how much do you give
them profit share? I'll tell you how I
come to it. I think how much would
someone need to make that has the level
of skill required to thrive in this
position. And so let's say that I I
think that the skills that are required
here would require 5 years of experience
and $150,000 a year. Okay. So I'm going
to say the on-target earnings OTE, all
right, is 150k. Okay. So what I'd
probably do is say, all right, well,
what is my average location make? And
let's say my average location makes
$250,000 in profit. All right. Well, I
don't want to give $250,000 in profit
straight to the that doesn't make any
sense for you as an owner, right? So
then what do I do? So I would probably
do something like this. You get 75k as a
base, so 50% and the other 50%, which
would be $75,000, would mean that you
would get, let's say, 10, whatever, 12
and 1/2%, I don't know what the math is
here. 12 and 1/2% of the profit from the
location. Now, if a location does really
well and does $350,000,
then all of a sudden this 12.5% is even
more. So, now they're at 185 or
whatever. Now, if they underperform and
let's say they're at 100k, well, then
they would only get an extra 12.5k,
right? And so, then they'd only make
whatever that is, $87,000. And so, this
still keeps them very invested as an
operator for the location and feeling
the top line and bottom line impacts of
what it costs to run the business. And I
want this person to be like I want their
picture on the wall and be like this is
John's location, right? And this is
where I love this from a long-term
perspective because this can become a
very easy career path for people. So,
people who are kind of low like if you
have a business that requires low or
medium-level skill, somebody can come
in, do an amazing job and they're like,
"Well, what's my long-term career path
here?" It's like, "Well, if you do an
awesome job, I'm happy to put you in our
newest location that's across town. So,
if you want to start that one up, you
can start here, but you got to prove
yourself over 3 to 5 years, right?" And
so, that way they get to know the
business, they get to know how to
operate it well, and then you can pull
them over and then this kind of gives
you this organic growth where people
have ownership in their futures. And so,
this took me a really long time to learn
and this was a mistake that I can now
tell you because now having looked at a
lot and we obviously have chains of
locations inside of acquisition.com, you
want to have this model, at least in my
opinion. That's Alex's two cents. And if
you're curious how this math works, I'm
going to spell it out really easily for
you right now. You have your on-target
earning of what you think the person
would make if they do a normal job, like
you're not going to fire them, they're
fine. You then say half of that's going
to be base and the other half would be
for medium performance. That gets them
to the medium outcome. Now, if they have
exceptional performance, whatever that
percentage was to equal half of the base
or half of the extra half of their of
the on-target earnings, then they would
get more if it goes up. And if it goes
down, then that percentage is going to
be less, so they're going to be below
their on-target earnings. That's the
earnings for the person. So, I didn't do
this and it was really hard and if I
could do it again, that's what I would
have done. Number 12, this is a big one.
Nail it before you scale it. So, this
goes to the whole rush thing, right? I
was in this massive rush to do what? I
have no idea. I just everything was like
everything is has to happen tomorrow.
Everything has to happen tomorrow. And I
ended up making a ton of mistakes, not
getting locations perfectly situated
before starting the next one. And so
basically like I'm still selling it
location one when I'm starting location
two, right? Just not smart, right? It
should have been like, "Okay, how do we
get this so that our churn's really low?
How do we get it so that it's continuing
to compound year over year over year?
How do we make sure that we're
absolutely full capacity? How do we know
that like people are selling and
marketing all their own without me?"
Once that occurs and I let it sit for 6
months and it's still growing straight,
then I can maybe start the next one,
right? And so if you're like thinking
through this, my litmus test for this is
that number one, you shouldn't care
about your second location before the
first one can run without you, period.
Number two,
don't go to a new one until the old one
is growing without you for 6 months
straight. That's my rule of thumb. 6
months straight of growth without you
doing it. Now, to be clear, a lot of
business owners or small business owners
for local business especially are like,
"Oh no, this thing runs without me." No,
no, no, no, no. I'm not saying like,
"Oh, uh you don't show up to the gym,
therefore it runs without you." There's
many things that are required in a
business. You're the operator. You don't
necessarily train the sessions, you
don't necessarily like do the billing,
but like you're still required to make
decisions and and deal with customers
all that stuff. No, we need somebody
else who completely encapsulates that
business. And here's the the deal, this
this goes on number uh a num with number
11. Here's how you have the
conversation. So, John, I want you to I
want you to be the uh the operator for
this location. You're going to have a
profit share, your on target earnings is
twice what you're currently making, and
here's the stick. Cool, you've been
working here for 5 years. I want to give
you that opportunity. Okay. So, here's
the deal. You're going to make 10% of
the profit of this location on one
condition. Get it? Yes. Here's the
condition. This
doesn't ring.
That's the deal.
So, let me explain. Let's role-play
this. A pipe breaks in the middle of the
session. It's leaking out of the
ceiling. What do you do? Call a plumber?
Right. So, skip the call me part and
just call the plumber. Okay, let's try
it again. Let's say someone has a heart
attack on the floor. What are you going
to do? Not call you. Correct. Now,
someone has a heart attack on the floor
probably would call you. But, for the
purpose of our illustration, what would
you do first? Call 911 cuz that's what
I'm going to do. Right? So, just think
one extra step and then do that thing
and you have permission up to $1,000 of
cost to not have to call me. And so, we
want to make sure though, to be clear,
you want to give So, this is a good one
for for everybody to write down. Is that
you want to pair responsibility with
authority. So, when you only have one or
the other, it creates problems. If
someone has authority and no
responsibility, you have an
Right? They just tell people what to do,
but they are not responsible for
anything. It's just people just go
sticking their nose in other people's
business. On the other hand, this is far
more common, business owners give
someone the responsibility but not the
authority. They say, "You're responsible
for all this stuff." And they're like,
"Okay, well, I need to do X, Y, and Z."
And they're like, "No, no, no, no. Uh
you can't do that without my
permission." It's like, "Well, then
they're just handcuffed. They can't do
anything." Right? So, you have to give
authority that is equal to the
responsibility. If you think that 90% of
problems can get solved for $500 or
less, then give it to them. If you know
that customer escalations, there's a
problem with a customer, you say, "Hey,
up to 100% of what a customer uh spent
with us in the last month, you're able
to spend on a discretionary for people
who are upset." So, if someone spends
$100 with us this month, you can spend
100% of their $100 to make them happy
and not have a bad experience. Right? If
they're You know, and this is where like
somebody has a new kid, someone's parent
died, someone's car breaks down,
whatever it is, like that going that
extra mile and using this kind of
discretionary fund is what you want to
empower a location owner operator to
have. So, they can actually make
decisions of value. And so, the nail
before you scale it concept works across
all industries. All right? So, like if
you have a software company, if you're
losing customers and churning them out,
why would you scale it? Like you don't
just like pour more water into a leaking
bucket. Why would you do that? If you
have an agency and you're you know,
you're like, "Oh, look, we're we're We
finally have ads that are converting for
us." Yeah, cool. Great. That's step one.
Don't scale them anymore. See why
customers are leaving. And if customers
are consistently leaving, maybe you're
serving the wrong customers. So maybe
you shouldn't scale because you're just
going to create a churn factory, right?
And the thing is is that the vast
majority of businesses are this. They,
especially small businesses. And this is
actually the difference between small
businesses and big businesses is that
small businesses become medium-sized
businesses typically by just spending a
ton more on marketing and sales because
they learned how to do it, but they
never figured out how to keep customers.
And if you never figured out when you're
small, you're definitely not going to
have it when you're when you're rich
when you're big. All right? Because it's
easier to fix it when you're small and
there's going to be natural degradation
of things as things scale. And so if you
can't do it when you're small, it's even
harder when you're big. And so you want
to nail it first and then as you scale
it, keep fixing it so it stays nailed.
And a great test for that 6-month
walk-away period from point 11 is just
take a vacation. Take a 1-month
vacation. See what happens. You'll be
able to see what breaks. It's actually a
great test. So let me give you let me
give you my my lesson number 13 I
learned from the gyms is unscalable
beginnings. So when I started my first
location Huntington Beach, I had one PT
client who paid me like $4,000 a month.
And it's because they trained 5 days a
week and it was like hour and a half or
2-hour long sessions. And so it was 10
hours a week of PT basically guaranteed
that I would do with them. And so it
made me a significant amount every
month. And I basically just lived on
that. Now, is that part of the model?
No. But I did it because that's like
what allowed me to be more aggressive
with the expansion of the business. I
could take all the cash that come in,
buy new equipment, fix things, whatever,
you know, hire more people. And so there
are some things that you're going to do
in the beginning that will not scale
with the business and that's okay. So
you just want to make sure that your
nail it portion doesn't include the
unscalable parts that I still think you
should absolutely consider doing to make
the whole process a lot easier on
yourself. And so it's like if you have
your core business, fine. If you have
five five clients who pay you more
personalized attention for stuff so you
can like live on that money, part of you
is going to be like, "Man, I should just
do this." And maybe you should. But if
you're trying to build an asset that has
value independent of your time, then
this is what we're building. So I just
like I wouldn't Yes, is it a
distraction? But being poor is even
bigger distraction. And so it's really
like the lesser of which evil. Right? If
you're like, man, it's just I'm so
stressed about payroll and stuff. Like
if you have this other cash flow thing
and to be clear, this isn't woman in the
in the in the red dress. I'm talking
like you're not building another another
business. It's like you're just straight
selling time so that at a higher, you
know, a higher ticket for your extra
cheese or something so that you can
build this asset. So I'm okay with that.
And that sounds like it's contrary to
the woman in the red dress, but we're
not building two businesses. You're just
accepting very high ticket clients that
you can on a one-on-one basis, not
building a separate business, minimizing
the time requirement. And so for me with
my personal training client, I did the
middle of the day. So I like it it
worked out fine for me. So I finished my
morning sessions, I'd have a couple
hours, I'd do two hours, uh, you know,
with him and then I'd start my evening
sessions. So I basically just started
that as my my evening sessions. And
that's just what allowed Alex to eat
Chipotle. And if you're like, wait, I
thought you ate the expired food. I did
that too, but sometimes a week to a day
it expires. So I had to eat Chipotle in
the meantime. All right. So this next
one's really big, especially if you have
a team, which basically anybody who has
a business eventually has a team, is
that doing is not the same as teaching.
So it's one thing to be able to sell,
it's another thing to be able to teach
to sell. It's one thing to be able to
train, another thing to be able to teach
to train. One thing to be able to run
ads, another thing to be able to teach
people to run ads. And so I had this
kind of ego thing where I loved being
the most valuable player. Right? I loved
being able to come in and save the day,
put the team on my back and everyone's
like, Rocky, right? You know, whatever,
right? And that was something that
handicapped me. And so I wanted to be
the best salesperson, but what a
terrible thing to want if you want to
have a business. And so I had to shift
my identity to being I want to be the
best sales teacher. I want to be the
best marketing teacher. I want to be the
best operations teacher. Right? And by
doing that, it shifted how I saw what
winning looked like. And so before this,
it was like, oh, they went two for six
today. I could go in and close five out
of six. Okay, cool. Well, that means
that you suck as a teacher, not that
you're great as a sales guy. And so, you
have to basically level up your game and
think this is the new identity that I
have to be. And this took me This took
me a long time to learn. And I'll tell
you the first time that this was like
very real for me is that um I went home
for for Christmas. Uh this is like the
first year of the gym and I was very
afraid uh to do that. And I had trained
uh these girls who had sold tanning
before. And so, I taught them how to
sell the challenge. And I remember when
I was driving I remember where I was. I
was driving on the road to to go back to
my actual house where I lived when I
grew up. And I get this phone call and
they're like, "Yeah, you know, the day
ended." And I was like, "How'd you do?"
And they were like, "Oh, we had uh you
know, we had we had five people show uh
sold two." And I was like, "You sold
them though. Like credit card like it
ran like the whole thing?" They were
like, "Yeah, one was paid in full the
other was a split pay." And I was like,
"Hold on. So, today $750 came in. Like
it pri- It said successful next to it."
And they were like, "Yeah." They were
like acting they were like, "Why is this
guy being so weird?" And I ended up
pulling the car over and I remember it
was like one of the few times that I had
like a real big emotional like
experience uh one of the few times ever.
And I almost got like teared up because
it was it was the first moment where I
realized like I wasn't the one who's
going to have to make every dollar in
this business. And it was the first
moment where I realized the value of
transferring a skill to somebody else.
Cuz until then I just wanted to be MVP.
I just wanted to be the best trainer,
the best sales guy, the best whatever.
But as soon as I gave it to someone else
it was like it was like I had tasted
freedom. And once I had that I was like,
"I'm going to get great at this." And I
think a big part of honestly the stuff
that you guys see today with YouTube and
the books and things like that like is
because I shifted my perspective from
being like, "It's one thing to learn. I
have to learn it I have to learn it so
that I can teach it rather than I want
to learn it so that I can be the best
person at I don't think I'm the best at
basically anything. If I can be one of
the best at teaching the thing, then I
can help thousands and millions of
people and that's a much higher leverage
skill. So, the next thing kind of bolts
onto that which is lesson 15 for me, was
simple. All right, simple scales, fancy
fails. All right. Now, it's like, okay,
well, duh. All right, but let me talk
about this within the context of systems
and and training. So, a lot of people
have these very, very complex sales
systems. And I honestly just try and cut
more and more things out of the sales
stuff that I teach because I want it to
be something that someone can
immediately pick up. And so, the whole
like Closer Framework came out of just
trying to make this as simple as
possible. Clarify why they're here when
they come in. Label them with the
problem to show that you listen. Ask
them you overview the past experience,
the past pain, what have they tried so
far? Then sell the vacation, tell them
about our thing, make the offer. If they
say no, explain to where their concerns.
Once they buy, then reinforce the
decision, tell them they did a good job.
That's it. That's all we're doing,
right? And so, I used to have all these
like really complex things that I try to
like and it became really hard for
people to learn. And then I was like,
okay, I just need this so that somebody
who has no idea how to sell can go
through this thing and then be able to
sell afterwards. And I remember when I
started launching gyms that the sales
training I had in total was like an hour
and 15 minutes, the whole thing. And
what's crazy is that that sales training
came from the intention of like people
have to watch this and at the end be
able to close. And what's so interesting
is that I see like lots of sales
trainings that are like sold and things
like that on the internet. They're
they're you know, they're 100 hours
long. But I had a sales training that
was like, just do this. Don't do
anything else. Just do this. And I only
had to get them to understand seven
steps in this process. And if they could
understand the seven steps, they could
close. And so, I would encourage you to
first think, what is the absolute
minimum required in order to close a
sale? What is the absolute minimum
required in order to make a great
training session, right? And then try
and boil it down to the core components
rather than make it complicated cuz
comp- the complexity piece again makes
you feel important, like you're so
advanced. When in reality, like there's
probably fewer things that matter than
you think. All right, so this is a very
kind of technical advanced thing that I
learned from the gyms, which is that you
want zero cost upsells. Okay, so what
does that mean? So, I realized early on
that people would come in the gym and
then I'd sell them service, right? But
they also would want other things after
that. They would want apparel, they
would want apps, they would want food,
they would want supplements. Like
there's all these other things, right?
And so I realized that it would cost me
about 200, well, later 200, earlier cost
me less, but let's call it 100 200
dollars to acquire a customer. Okay. The
question I then asked myself was, is
there something that I can sell them
that costs me no time cuz selling
service cost me time, right? There's
something I could sell that cost me no
extra effort that could recoup that
original cost. And the answer was yes.
And so if you sell a service, I think
one of the easiest things you can do is
upsell products that go with the service
that you just make your margin on and
you can liquidate your ad cost up front.
And so for me I sold supplements. I'd
sell two 300 dollars supplements every
person and the margin I made on the
supplements was usually enough to cover
the cost of all of my advertising
revenue. So basically I would just
recover all my advertising bill with my
supplements so I could spend whatever I
wanted to get customers because then all
of my service revenue was basically
gravy on top. And so the goal that I
would like don't think oh that doesn't
work for my business. Ask it
differently. Think how could I make
something like this work for my
business? So like if I have a yoga
studio that's like fine, sell yoga
blocks, sell mats, sell sell leggings,
whatever cuz they're going to want that
stuff. There's always going to be a
couple other things that someone's going
to want when you have a service
typically. And if you're like, well I
can't immediately think of some. Fine,
then give yourself more than immediately
to think about it because you only have
to figure out one or two things and it
change your business forever. Also, pro
tip, if you want, you can you can sell a
guarantee. So guarantees don't have to
be free. You can sell a guarantee. So
you can sell your normal service and if
for an extra 10% we'll guarantee this.
People will buy a guarantee and
guarantees are basically zero extra cost
if they don't take it. And so it's like
only one out of 10 people who buys a
guarantee ends up taking me up on it.
It's like okay, well then 90% of the
time it's just profit. Pro tip. And you
can also charge more than 10% obviously.
17,
I learned the power of what I called
internal plays. All right, so internal
plays
are basically internal promotions that
you run to your existing customers in
the list. And so, one of the things I
realized is that customers get bored of
things, and so you just need to sell
them more stuff.
And so, I would say, "Okay, you know, we
have our normal gym membership, but
we're going to run a big booty boot
camp. We're going to run uh buns and
guns. We're going to run a sex you know,
get your sexy back, whatever." Right?
And
you laugh, but this is this is this is
how it was, right? I didn't add an hour
program for dudes. And the thing is is
it sold. It worked great, but here is
the best part is that I remember the
first time I did this was big booty boot
camp. So, Sam, the guy that I that I set
up for said, "Hey, uh send these
emails." So, I was like, "All right, so
cool." So, I sent these emails that were
about big booty boot camp. And the
emails all of a sudden like came back
and were like, "I'm in. I'm in. I'm in."
on my on my emails. I was like, "Holy
cow." And I got 30 people to spend 300
bucks, I mean $9,000, which was huge for
me, right? At the time. I made $9,000.
And the crazy thing is it was a 6-week
program, and it was only it was a
90-minute session once a week. So, they
got six sessions for $300. So, I was
like,
And so, with 30 people, I was able to do
six sessions and make $9,000. It was
$1,500 a session. Like, that was so much
more than the amount of money that I was
not really making per session. And so,
the thing is is that these types of
plays are they're just free money. And
so, what you want to do is I would say
have some sort of promotional cadence
where like once a quarter, every 12
weeks or so, you run some sort of
defining thing for your customers. And
here's the crazy part is that in a
business especially like this, like a
gym business, the margins historically
are like 12 and 1/2% that's the average
like micro gym margins. It's not a lot.
And the average micro gym does like 30
360,000 a year. So, the average gym
owner is making like 30 to 40,000 a
year. Not a lot to take home, and
they're working like 80 hours a week.
And so, you might hear $9,000 and be
like, "Oh, well, that's nothing." It's
like, "Well, 9 * 4 is 36. You normally
take home 36. Then making another 36
doubles your income. Would you double
your income for like a couple emails
four times a year?" Yeah. So, do it.
Right? And so every business has these
opportunities that there's something
that you can do, a very defined thing.
Like there wasn't it like Big Booty
Bootcamp was one body part, right? And
so think about your your business,
whatever you serve, you probably serve
the whole body of someone's business.
You serve the whole body of their
computer. You serve the whole body of
their phone, whatever. And then you say,
"Cool, I'm just going to peel off one
portion of that and then say, 'Hey, all
my customers, any of you want this one
thing like really maxed out?'" And 10%
or 20% of the customers would be like,
"Yeah, I'm interested in that." And then
boom. And that thing that you end up
selling is actually super high margin.
Internal plays are almost all profit.
You can run them four times a year,
recommend it. Yeah, it's it's all it's
basically all profit because you already
paid the cost of acquiring the customer.
And so the only cost is the cost of
delivery. So for me, for the six
sessions, if I wanted to like, you know,
charge based on my time, right? I pay a
trainer maybe, you know, 20 20 back
then, you know, 20 bucks an hour for for
90 minutes, I pay $30 * 6, 180 bucks for
9 grand.
98% margins? Like what are we talking
about? Like let's do it. Right? Like
unbelievable. And so those opportunities
exist. You just have to find them. Yeah,
if I if I wanted to acquire 30 new
customers, I would have to pay $6,000.
Right? And so like here, that's why this
is free money. And most most services
have if you at least have a decently
designed business model, your gross
margin should be 80% or more. And so if
you're running 80% gross margins and you
sell something you make $10,000, you
make eight net. That's a great deal. The
problem is just all the other costs of
the business, but all those are fixed
already. You don't have to pay cost to
acquire customers, you already have your
fixed costs covered. So this is just
incremental revenue, which typically
should be high margin for you. So let me
give you a quick one. So here's number
18.
Is a lot of people and I read this a
lot, like people have the you know, they
they write books and they make content
and they're like, "Here here's why this
thing works." I really try hard and you
guys are welcome to call me out on it. I
try really hard to not say why things
work. And I think the reason I do that
is because I have no idea.
And I don't think anyone else does
either. So, we make postulates, we
create these hypotheses whether how
these work, but we have no split test,
we have no no research, right? So,
instead, I have spent almost no time in
my life trying to figure out why things
work, and just figure out a big bag of
things that do work. And I just try to
recommend those things. And so, on my
channel, that's pretty much where all I
spend my time. I was like, "This stuff
works. I don't know why it works. I just
know that it works." So, run an internal
play a couple times a year, it'll
probably make you more money. If you
have upsells, try and have them be zero
cost, zero work upsells, so that you can
just make more money up front, right? If
you do it simpler, more people do a good
job, right? I don't Like, "Why?" I don't
know. But, when you have fewer steps,
it's easier for people to remember,
right? So, next little lesson, this is a
big one.
It's a little lesson, but it's a big
one. Agency, if you're a small business
owner, there are two core things in
every business. Acquiring customers,
and delivering to those those customers.
Those are the two core elements of a
business. Everything else, you can
outsource. Now, I'm not saying you
should outsource it, I'm just saying
it's possible to. But like, what is the
core business that you actually run?
And so, if you have a business, then
getting customers is a part of that. And
so, I think agencies have a use, but not
as something that you rely on. And so, I
would recommend learning to acquire
customers, which is why I make all the
stuff that I do, right? If you're like,
"How do I acquire customers?" I'll show
you eight ways how to do it inside of
this book. So, inside the Leads Book, I
show eight different ways to get
customers. Warm outreach, cold outreach,
posting content, running ads, getting
customer referrals, getting affiliates,
other business to refer you business,
getting agencies, right, to run stuff
for you, but I'll show you how to how we
do that in the lesson I'm about to share
with you. And then, employees to do all
those things on your behalf. Now, you as
a person can only do the core four. You
get other people to do these other four
things on your behalf. So, how does an
agency fit into this? So, an agency
usually has a mastery of some sort of
platform or method. So, they're either
really good at like email outbound, and
they set appointments for you, or
they're really good at making content,
they click click clips for you, they're
really good at running paid ads on
YouTube, they're really good at running
Google Ads, they're really good at SEO.
They have some method of getting
customers. Okay. My objective with an
agency, if I have to do it, is that I
want to beg, borrow, and do whatever I
need to do in order to get them to teach
me how they do it. And I prefer this
method because agency owners tend to
know how to do this better than people
who teach it because they're actually
doing it every day. I usually go into
the intention with an agency owner to
say, "Hey, here's my intention. I will
sign up with you, but I will do it with
the intention of learning everything I
can from you so I can eventually replace
you." And so, my actual story around
this, I tell in the agency chapter in
this book, which is that I got on the
phone with a bunch of agencies, and they
were like $3,000 a month, and I could
not afford that for at all. And so, I
knew how to run ads at the time because
I'd learned from that that weekend boot
camp that I did at the very beginning of
my uh gym, but I needed to I need to get
better, right? And so, finally, it was
like the third or fourth call, I was
like, "Hey, man, like, what would it
take?" It's a magic question. "What
would it take for you to teach me
one-on-one?" He's like, "I don't sell my
time." And I said, "Okay, what would it
take?" It's American. There's a price. I
was like, "Well, you know, would you do
it for a million dollars an hour?" And
he was like, "Well, yeah." I was like,
"Okay, cool. So, there's a price. So,
you will do it. So, just give me a price
that you think you would do it for." And
he said, "Uh 750 an hour." And he said
that, and I was like, "Deal." And so, he
ended up doing once a week with me for
an hour, and he taught me how he would
set up my ads. I was like, "This way you
don't have to you don't have to in-
include your team. You don't have any
more, you know, costs to the business.
Like, I'll just have It's basically just
It's just one call a week, man. 750
bucks. It's all And so, he said, "Sure."
And so, for the first few weeks, the
deal was, "I'm the only one who touches
the computer. So, you show me what
you're doing, but I'm going to I'm going
to do it, right?" And so, I'm going to
So, you can tell me where I'm messing up
if I get stuck. Once he taught it to me,
and if I didn't know how like why he was
doing something, I was like, "Explain
your decision-making process." And then,
after the sixth time that I sixth call
that I did, I like was like, "I don't
need this guy." I did two more calls, I
didn't have anything that came up. And
so, for $6,000, basically the cost of 1
month of running this agency, I was able
to learn the skill from the one of the
best agency owners, and then I used that
skill for like the rest of my
advertising career. I learned how to do
national ad campaigns, I learned how to
do retargeting, and those were the two
lessons that I really learned I didn't
know how to do, and that's what I
learned. And so, if you're a small
business owner, mastering how to get
customers is one of the most important
skills you can have. You can hire an
agency, but you do it because you want
to learn from them, in my opinion.
Number 20. So, this is a mistake that I
made, too. This is a crazy mistake. So,
this is absolute versus
relative return. So, I remember that I
had other gyms in the area started
catching on to the challenge, right? It
was working really, really well, and
they saw that I was doing well. So, then
they started running ads. And these guys
were more, you know, advanced business
owners than me. I was 20-something,
whatever.
And so, I remember uh this guy moved
into the area, and he was running ads,
and I asked him how much he was
spending. And he was like, "Ah, he's
like, I think we're spending like 500 a
day." And I was like, "500 a day? Holy
And I'm spending like 50 to 100 a day.
And so, this guy comes in and like 5 to
10 X's my spend. I was like, "Oh my god,
he's going to take all the ad space."
And the thing is is that he was willing
to And I was like, "Well, what's your
return?" He's like, "Ah, he's like, I
don't know. I think we're getting like
four to one on it." But that means that
he's spending 15 grand and making 60,
right? And here I was, you know,
spending 1,500 bucks a month, being
really excited that I'm getting 10 to
one. So, I spend 1,500, make 15 grand, I
net 13 five. This guy is spending 15,
making 60, netting 45. And I was like,
"Wait a second." So, this whole time I
was obsessing about like every little
incremental dollar, I was missing the
bigger picture, which was like, at some
point, you just need to spend more
money. You just need to do more. And so,
I was getting I was like, "Oh, no. Oh,
we went from we went from, you know, 13
to one to 10 to one. I got to I got to
stop." It's like, "No, man. Like, if I
could get two to one on a million
dollars and make a million dollars by
spending a million to make two, I would
rather do that than get 10 to one on 10
grand. And so, the the big lesson I had
to learn was that I was obsessed with my
ROAS and not the absolute amount of
money that I was making in profit,
right? And so, if the ROAS dropped, I
would stop spending money. And so, the
the big TLDR on this is just focus on
the bottom line of like how much money
am I going to make rather than being as
obsessed with those. Now, this is
especially around local markets, right?
You want to make you I mean, for any
business you want to maximize the amount
of money you're making. Obviously,
having big LTV to CAC discrepancies is
great and I'm a big advocate of that,
but I don't want to do that to the
long-term detriment of the total amount
of money that I'm making. Don't break
what works. All right, so I'll tell you
a very sad story. So, I had my gym and I
had I kind of like tweaked my my my
sessions uh a few times from when I
started to like try and make them
better. And I got to the point where my
gym was packed. Like I I had two
sessions running at any given time. I
had a strength session and a cardio
session. And it was it was packed to the
brim. I had 40, 50 people and I only
had, you know, 3,500 sq ft of actual
like gym space. So, it was packed.
What's crazy is that because I couldn't
fit any more people in, what I decided
to do was I decided to cut the session
times in half and consolidate it to only
one type of session and combine them
again. And what happened next was I
churned out like a third of my customer
base cuz they were like, "Why'd you
change it? It was so great." And it was
because I let the the capacity tail wag
the business dog.
And so, basically, what I should have
done was say, "Oh,
uh I nailed it.
I should open another location." Right?
Now, if I wasn't making enough profit,
then I should have fixed my price. If I
have huge amount of demand, everybody's
showing up and everyone loves it, then I
probably had more price flexibility.
But, basically, what I reasoned with
myself was, "Oh, I just need to find a
way to fit more people so I can make
more money." But, it was the wrong I
messed it up. Like, if you finally
figure out what actually like what
people love, that is the hardest thing
to do. And so, once they love it, if
your business model is profitable, don't
mess with it. Just do more. Go open up
more locations. If people love it and
it's not profitable, then fix your
pricing. Don't fix the product. Like if
they love it, they love it. That's the
hardest part. Pricing is easy to change.
Changing what you deliver is super
tough. That was one of the hardest
lessons that I had to learn. And so, the
most elusive thing is getting customers
who absolutely adore your product and
service, tell their friends, and bring I
remember what the energy of the gym was
like at that point. And it was a
terrible mistake for me. Ah, number 22.
Work your leads.
As we get As we get further in the
numbers, they're just going to get
sillier and sillier. No, work your
leads. So, I realized that when I worked
the leads, we got like three or four
times more sales than if my team worked
the leads. And what I realized was the
incredible lever that lead nurture had
on the throughput of my advertising.
Even larger than the throughput of
closing. And so, like maybe I could
close 80% of people walking in the
doors, but a good closer would close,
let's say, half. And so, the difference
between 50% and 80% is a I don't know
what the math is there. Call it a 60 or
70% difference, okay? But the difference
between getting 10% of the leads in the
door and 50% of the leads in the door is
a 5x difference. And so, it made more
sense for me to put my leverage on
figuring out how to work the leads
harder and better and faster than even
trying to obsess about close rates. And
so, this is something and like this is
for you. I'm like, I'm going to I'm
going to tell you a different story
that's from the future. So, I was
recently talking to a business owner and
he was closing 55% of his leads. Leads,
not shows, not calls, leads. 55% and I
was like, "Dude, how are you doing
that?" He was like, "Oh, I pay one girl
full-time. She has no other job but to
call leads the moment they come in. And
I want to give you an idea of of here.
He gets about two to three leads a day.
That's his business. Two to three leads
a day, that's all he gets. And he pays a
girl full-time, and the only job
description is be available. That's it.
So, 24/7, whenever a lead comes in, you
stop what you're doing, you call the
lead. That's it. That's the only job she
had. But, and think about how crazy it
is, cuz as a business owner, you're
like, "Well, I should give them
something else." So, well, think about
this.
Most people in his position close 10% of
their leads. And we've all heard the
statistic that if you call a lead within
60 seconds, you have a 391% increase in
sales. Okay, 391%, let me translate that
into x's. That's a 4x, let's say 4.9x
for business. Almost a 5x. If you have
something that could 5x the amount of
sales that you're getting from the leads
that you're working right now, is there
something right now that you could do
that's more valuable than that?
Probably not. And so, the the question
is, or the interesting thing is is that
the cost of actually achieving that is
the cost of one maniac that you have to
pay to stop whatever they're doing to
call the leads. That's it.
And so, think about what the difference
of a 2x, 3x, 4x, in revenue would be for
your business in terms of efficiency on
the leads that you're currently getting.
And then, if that number is larger than
what you would pay one maniac to call
the leads, find the maniac and pay them.
And so, I figured out way too late that
lead nurture often times is a a larger
potential throughput. There's a larger
discrepancy in performance on nurture
than almost any part on acquisition.
And so, we focus at acquisition.com on
that super heavily because it's one of
the easiest, lowest risk levers that you
can you don't even have to change any of
your marketing, you don't have to change
any of your delivery. You just nurture
better. Okay, number 23. So, this is
going to be a callback, which is never
rely on another business to feed yours.
Now, I made an entire video about what I
did, which is that if you only have one
kind of point of failure, that becomes
the weak link in the chain. And so, I
told you about the the gym mastermind
that I joined, and everybody there was
running Groupon. Well, guess what
happened when Groupon stopped working?
They were all out of luck, right? You
have to You ideally want to have
multiple ways to get customers. Now, I
like to have multiple ways to get
customers as I get bigger. I want to
have one channel that I can reliably get
customers when I'm starting out. But, if
it's another business that's my source,
I don't like that.
So, there's a difference between having
a single channel risk versus another
business risk. So, if another business
can choose to shut off my my lead flow
tomorrow, very risky. And so, if I say,
"Okay, I I do door knocking or I do
outbound." That is one channel and that
can scale up usually to about a million
dollars a month. And then at that point,
you can kind of diversify. Now, if
you're brick and mortar or local, it's
one of those businesses is that's a
little bit different than like the
online or national space, which is that
it's easier to have multiple streams.
Typically with brick and mortar, you're
going to have naturally a little bit
more word of mouth. It's easy to set up
your Google search terms. Winning local
SEO, not that hard. Running paid ads
local, not that hard. All right? And so,
it's more common to have multiple
streams open in a local business than it
is at a national level
just because of the nature of basically
ease of competition there. The next
three lessons are going to be 24, 25,
26, which is close to when I finished
the gym. And so, my gym my gym season
and so, we're going to end on there. So,
24, 25, 26. All right. And so, all three
of these are going to be around people.
And so, the first thing is around what
you have to pay for people. All right?
So, if you can't pay to get pre great
people, you're going to have to work to
get great people. So, let me put it
differently. It is faster to get better
people by raising how much you're
willing to pay. You'll just have better
quality candidates that are coming
towards you if you raise basically the
ticket or the barrier to entry. That
being said, I have had exceptional
people that came for less.
You just have to talk to like 10 times
more people to find those people. So,
it's basically like to be a video game
you either have to like grind or pay,
right? It's like you you have to like
work to level up or you can pay to level
up. Well, if you're poor or you're
starting out in your business, it just
means that you're going to work and the
work is outreach and running, you know,
job postings and doing a lot of
interviews and kissing a lot of toads
before you find your magic prince, which
hey, I'm glad that you found your magic
prince, which was your customer success
rep. All right. And so, you either got
to grind or you got to pay. So, that's
number one. That's number 24, but number
one for people. So, number 25 is the
platinum rule. And this was a really
eye-opening experience for me. I had an
employee that taught me one of the most
interesting lessons I've ever learned in
managing people. So, my single best
manager across all my gym locations,
everyone loved him. He was an amazing
trainer, he had great energy, he was in
shape, he was great at sales, he was
awesome. So, I ended up promoting him to
manager and he did an amazing job, one
of the best managers I've ever had. And
at like month six, he came to me and he
was like, "Hey, man, I don't want to be
manager anymore." And I was like,
"What's going on? What's wrong? Like,
let's figure this out." And he was like,
"I just don't like the stress of being
manager." He's like, "I'd rather just
like train clients, train myself, go
home." And I was like,
"Well, so you still want to work here?"
He's like, "Yeah, I know, I love it
here." And I was like, "Okay." I was
like, "So, you just want to go back to
your old job?" And he was like, "Yeah."
So, I was like, "You're going to make
half as much money." He said, "I'll just
be poor then." And I remember him saying
that and it was like my world like
twirled around me. I was like, "I don't
understand this at all." But he said it
with so much conviction. I was like, "I
don't understand it, but I respect it."
And the lesson that I took away from
that was not everyone's motivated by the
same things as me and to the same degree
it means that they're motivated by other
things and I have to learn what those
other things are so that I can build
career paths and roles and incentives
that are right for them. And so, that
was the whole concept of the platinum
rule rather than the golden rule.
Instead of like treat others the way you
want to be treated, it was treat others
the way they want to be treated. And
that was my big takeaway that I've tried
to stick with myself to this day that I
still mess up all the time, but it was
just like it was such a crazy lesson I
figured I'd share it. So, 26 on people,
can you be friends with your employees?
This is a a controversial one.
Employees? Question mark? Friends?
Question mark? I'll tell you the
difference. So, when I started I was
friends with all my employees. Whatever
the professional line was, I definitely
didn't have it.
And so, I was just friends cuz I was
20-something, right? And all the people
working for me were 20-something. Like,
we're all just like a bunch of bunch of
hooligans, right? Like, trying to run a
business. Basically, I didn't run that
well, right? Like, I would show my
emotions on my sleeves. If I was upset,
they would be upset. I'd take my
emotions out on them. And so, like when
I needed them to change something, it
was weird cuz we're friends. I'm like,
"Hey, man, can you you know, like it
just was it sucked." So, I then kind of
created the rule like you can't be
friends with your employees, right? And
so, I kind of lived that way for a while
and that maintained a professional line.
And I would say that where I'm at now in
my career is that you can be friends
with your employees as long as you
maintain a clear line, which is that you
they have to respect. And the easiest
way that I have delineated this is
literally doing a hat change. Sounds
silly, but it doesn't have to be an
actual hat. But I I'll start a
conversation be like, "Friend hat." And
then I'll talk whatever I'm going to
talk. And sometimes I'm like, "Hey, man,
boss hat. Like, this is this is what's
going wrong. Like, you need to change
this." Right? And by being able to
maintain that and I don't know if that's
a maturity thing or whatever's happened.
First was like, friends with everyone,
that didn't work. Friends with no one,
uh you can do that, but I would say like
life is lonely. Um and then the you
know, the third version at least where
I'm at now is that these are the people
that help me accomplish my goals. I
mean, I can't imagine a better
definition of a friend. People who like
try to help you accomplish what you're
what you're trying to do. And so, the
people that work at acquisition.com, I'm
friends with many of them. But we also
have a line of kind of like mutual
respect and professionalism because at
the end of the day, this is the kind of
you know, we're business athletes and
we're all on a team. And so, everyone
needs to perform. And so, it's kind of
having more like a coach relationship, I
think, where it's like a coach is still
I would say friends with the players,
but there's just some line that you
don't cross. And I think that that's
that's really what it comes down to.
Like, I'm there for them 100%. I'm
probably not going to like come in in
tears because my dog dies to somebody
who's on my team. Like, I don't think
that'd be appropriate, right? So, it's
just maintaining that line. So, these
are the 26 lessons I learned from
building my gyms. And if you want to see
me apply these lessons to a real
everyday business that's not at all in
this space, check out over here where I
help a stranger build a million-dollar
business and drive